hello everyone and welcome to another
game from Hikaru Nakamura's visit to
South Africa Johannesburg this is a game
from a simultaneous exhibition where he
faced over a hundred players he agreed
to play 100 players but Indian there
were 101 players before I showed the
game I would just like to say I got an
answer from chess comm they in fact did
change the sound of the pieces and they
also said that they have a couple of
sound things to choose from I was unable
to figure out where to change the sound
of the pieces so if any of you having
any idea do share in the comments but so
far I only decreased the volume of the
moves so as I haven't know they're
really annoying especially castling but
on the bright side you only have to hear
it twice in one game so let's get back
to this game like i said it's a it's a
simultaneous exhibition held in your
highness book south africa and the last
big simultaneous exhibition in johannes
Berg was the one Garry Kasparov held in
I believe it's 2012
or maybe 2011 and there was that big
fiasco work as part of said that one of
the players was too strong that he was
rated over 2200 and that no what no one
warned him about that but I will put a
link to this original video work as part
of complaints in the description below
if you want to check it out
I will also add in the description a
video of the original article about
Nakamura the visit to South Africa from
chess comm so be sure to check that out
as well so let's see the game here he
faces a chess player from South Africa
Alexandrov under Marv and van der Merwe
I don't know if that's how you pronounce
it he's he's rated somewhere around
fourteen hundred and something and
Nakamura is almost 2800 so the the
yellow difference between them is over
thirteen hundred points so so quite
quite a matchup so let's see this game
Nakamura has the white pieces in this
game he has the white pieces in all
games after all it's a simultaneous
exhibition so he opens with Knight to f3
the reti opening and we have Knight to
f6 b3 the names o Larsen variation and
the g6 by young Alexander we have Bishop
to b2 Bishop g7 efore
of course you can't capture the four
pawns since
Bishop ng7 would be captured so d6 we
have d3 and c5 g3 Knight to c6 Bishop to
g2 and a6 now we have castles by both
sides and Knight B to d2 Queen to c7
both sides simply developing pieces and
rook to e1 we have b5 and hironaka more
goes for the Knights the c4 preparing to
maneuver the night to e3 and from there
you will have some options of maybe
Reema nuvaring it against the d5 later
so we have b5 kicking the night away
with tempo but it that's fine that's
what Sakamoto wanted to night to e3 and
rook to b8 and this rook to b8 is a very
nice move it lines up the rook with this
undefended Bishop on me too if you know
sometimes positions just open up and
also it moves it from the a8 Square
since this Bishop is eyeing this eight
square through this long diagonal so
quite a useful move by young Alexander I
believe Alexander is 12 years old at the
time this game was played so night to d2
by Nakamura Knight to a5 and we have h3
Bishop to d7 and c4 by Nakamura and what
do you play here here Alexandra played
Knight to c6 and this is actually the
best response you don't want to capture
here or anything because black
definitely wants to keep control of the
C 4 square if you play something like B
captors on c4 then after night D
captures on c4 now white is controlling
the c-4 square and through some
maneuvering he can maybe even control d5
so black doesn't gain anything here so
after c4 Knight to c6 preparing Knights
to d4 as now he's seen a Kimura already
pushed c4 he pushed efore and now
there's there's sort of a hole here on
d4 which would be perfect for
Alexander's knight on c6 we have Knight
to d5 by Hikaru Knight captures C
captors and now Knight to d4 and this is
a this is a very strong night it's
actually a monster night you don't you
don't want to capture this night and you
don't want to allow it to stay there if
you capture it with the bishop then
after C capture some d4
now it's actually black that's
controlling the entire C file
you can't play something like Queen to
c1
if going to see one then simply rook
comes to see it and black is controlling
the C file if instead of Queen c1 you
try rock to see one then Queen to a5
comes this comes with an attack on the
a2 pawn and you either have to go back
with rook rook to a1 or maybe Queen to
c2 to try and defend it and control the
C file although you can't control it I
mean rook F the c8 is coming although
even Bishop to h6 would be an even
stronger move and after Bishop to h6
this would be simply too great of a
position for black so after this night
to d4 move he characterized rook to c1
we have Queen to b6 and now Hikaru
captures Bishop captures we have C
captures and B for not allowing this
pawn to be further pushed and making
room for his knight and b3 we have
Brooke f2 c8 Alexandra immediately grabs
the C file and now Knight comes to b3
rook captures on c1 Knight captures and
c1 Queen captures and c1 was also
possible but then again rook comes to c8
and Bishop to h6 Knight back to b3
rook to see it and now Queen to f3 and
here comes rook to c2 and this is a very
nice infiltration of the second rank
you're already attacking the a tube
point and hakarl definitely needs an
active move here in this position he
Cora plate Queen to f6 he played this
with the idea that the Queen will kind
of have to stay there on b6 defending
the d6 pawn and also if the Queen moves
then you have this Queen d8 idea
capturing the bishop on d7 but a much
better move was actually rook to e2
simply not allowing this rook to have
this beautiful square on c2 also now the
rook cannot capture the pawn and here
you can't can't really improve with a
move like Queen to c7 to further control
the C file because Hikaru can simply
capture and after Queen captures now
Queen to f6 is a much stronger move
because now you're directly threatening
the d6 pawn and the Queen d8 check or
grabbing the bishop on d7 so the Queen
would probably have to go back and now
black is still better he does have the
bishop pair a slightly better structure
but maybe maybe after f4
Kimura could grab some chances here
black doesn't have the luxury of
capturing as night capture 74 would come
so might be a better decision to play
rook to e2 here then immediately go
Queen f6 but okay Queen f6 by Nakamura
Queen to c7 and here we have F 4 and
this F 4 move this is where things start
to go wrong for Hikaru here you don't
really have an active move which
Nakamura definitely wants probably rook
to a 1 defending the a to pawn going
into a passive position and waiting for
young Alexander to make a mistake
instead Nakamura pushes f4 and the
position pretty much unfolds in young
Alexander's favor Queen to c3 now
bringing the Queen to c3 would an attack
on the rook on e1 and here it's very
hard to say there's really only one move
that isn't good but it kind of loves hit
hard to stay in the game or the move
rook to d1 here hikaru played rook to f1
and this simply doesn't work because now
you've taken DF 1 square that will be
very important for this Bishop and now
the bishop doesn't have anywhere to
retreat and Alexandria media to place
Queen to be 2 now he's attacking the
bishop on g2 Hikaru can play Queen d8
chair can capture bishop what he's
getting checkmated here so he plays
Bishop to f3 and getting the bishop out
of the way but now comes the Bishop
captures on h3 again threatening the
rook on f1 but you can't do anything
about this he caught rise F captures on
e5 but now comes rock to G to check and
of course if you capture you get Queen
kept course on G - checkmate
so only other movies King - h1 now comes
rope to h2 check King to g1 and here
comes Bishop to e3 check and it was in
this position that he Cara Nakamura
resigned the game so if you look at this
game it really looks like I don't know
it's very hard to believe such such a
game could happen between a player rated
1400 and Picaro Nakamura who is in the
top 10 chess players of the world of
course he resigned here because only
movies rock FQ and then comes
Queen captures on f2 this is checkmate
but yeah very hard to believe and a very
nice win for a younger Alexander even
though it was a simultaneous exhibition
it's still a very nice win with the
black pieces so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it out of out of a
hundred in one game Sakura Nakamura
played I believe the entire exhibition
lasted for seven hours seven seven
children well kids I don't know what the
age limit was but seven of them managed
to draw their games against Hikaru and
two of them won their game one of them
being Alexandra here so yeah like I said
I do hope you enjoyed it do check out
the video with Kasparov protesting in
his simultaneous exhibition in Johannes
Berg and to check out the original
article from chess calm I would like to
thank roll Alice Emma and Tom the
massacre for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon